metaphor is language's cure for the ills
entailed to it by language
explain that
that's another one that's just beautiful
that's a quote okay well it's a
beautiful question
well
it tries to compress the idea that
what are the ills i'm referring to well
the ills are
as i say that something that is only a
symbol or a representation of something
has to the thing that it represents
and in this way it's like money that
money can mean ultimately that i can
have lunch tomorrow with a friend or i
can you know buy a car or whatever it is
but
the
the money itself
only has that quality when it's cashed
back into life which is very complex
thing and language is rather like this
we can refer to things but the
experience that we refer to is no longer
in
the representation or the reference
it's it's implied by it that it isn't
actually
there
but that doesn't matter because
we think metaphorically all the time and
all language is metaphorical
interestingly the language of science
and philosophy is particularly heavily
dependent on for on metaphor a point
made by lakov and johnson in their
wonderful
books metaphors we live by and the
philosophy in the flesh
so
um
metaphor literally means a carrying a
cross
and so if you imagine there is this sort
of
divide or
gulf between
what the word
love means and the experience of love
metaphors
can carry us across that linguistic
divide they can take us back to the
experience of love and so something as
metaphorical as a shakespeare play or at
a piece of music or whatever and music
is metaphorical it uses metaphors based
on bodily movements so risings and
fallings and
resonances and all those things that are
experienced in a bodily sense so these
things are evoked in great art in ritual
in religion and
in narratives in mythology and and so
forth
and they take us back across the divide
from those sterile words to the thing
that those words were trying
but not able to evoke